speaking of rigged elections Donald
Trump thinks that even Saturday Night
Live is part of a media conspiracy to
bring down his presidential candidacy
Saturday Night Live opened up with yet
another one of these mocking
reenactments of the second presidential
debate and it was a parody that included
the moderators taking shots kung fu
style greeting between Trump and Hillary
Clinton making fun of everybody right
but of course making fun of Trump Trump
didn't like it he called for the show to
be pulled off of the air but of course
part of the critique is that Saturday
Night Live parodies of Trump and Hillary
Clinton are part of a plot to rig the
election in Hillary Clinton's favor
here's a tweet that Donald Trump say it
sent out saying watch Saturday Night
Live hit job on me time to retire the
boring and unfunny show Alec Baldwin
portrayal stinks media rigging election
the great thing is and with Trump some
double standard or conflicting statement
isn't too well hidden or too far behind
Trump was thrilled to host Saturday
Night Live 11 months ago he said it was
terrific and that he actually uh he
actually has hosted more than once here
is a Donald Trump tweet that he sent out
back in November of 2015 amazing evening
at Saturday Night Live now you might
write this off just as Trump being Trump
Trump being a little annoyed with the
portrayal of them but this is part of a
broader targeting of the media that
Donald Trump has been ramping up as his
poll numbers declined and the entire
setup of a rigged election is wrapped up
in Trump slamming of media outlets this
isn't exactly alpha male behavior is it
Pat you know Donald Trump jr. said and
others have said this is alpha male
behavior Pat Robertson Oh Trump's alpha
male crying about Saturday Night Live
portraying you in a way you don't like
not exactly alpha behavior he's like the
kid on the playground who cries and says
I'm gonna take my ball and go home yeah
or the one who says I'm gonna pour water
in the sandbox because it's time for me
to leave and I don't want anybody else
to play with it now I'm sort of
understanding all along what Trump has
meant when he said rigged election
anything that could be considered
strood as may be influencing opinion
qualifies as rigging an election for
Donald Trump so the entire election
clearly is rigged because there are
people journalists programs commentators
whoever that are trying to influence the
election one way or another next he's
going to say oh you know what the
American people rigged this election by
going out there and voting for Hillary
Clinton and the the sort of dumbest
thing about this for me is the SNL
parodies mimic Hillary Clinton as well
Trump's not the only victim or target of
the parodies now yes Trump is the most
outrageous candidate we've seen it seen
in a long time so of course you've got
more material on him than you do on
Hillary Clinton but uh for people who
think it's all just funny now Trump is
setting the stage for denying the
election results based on them being
rigged and I think you mentioned Pat
there's a significant portion of the
electorate right now who believes if
Trump loses it will be because of a
rigged election right of course SNL is
just working with the material that he
gives them yeah and if he wants that to
stop Issa just peachy just stop making
so many gaps and and policies that don't
make any sense it is very dangerous to
have a major party nominee attempting to
d legitimize the election all
Republicans should be standing up to
denounce this because it threatens the
very foundation of our democracy and
some Republicans did stand up and say
you know what I'm I support Trump I
don't support Hillary I'll be voting for
Trump but there's no rigging of this
election going on and some Republicans
are our I I mean I hate to use the term
bravely saying we have elections that
are legit uh in in in most of our states
that is not something that should be
considered brave but because of what's
going on in this culture around Trump in
the accusations of rigged election it
does kind of take some bravery let's
take a break next we will speak to a one
percenter who isn't buying much of what
Trump is saying about the estate tax
taxation and so much I'll stay with us